following some breaking news now here at
noon a major convention says no to las
vegas the national association of
broadcasters canceled
taking more than a hundred thousand
would-be attendees off the map the
reason
concerns over delta hector mejia joining
us now live from the newsroom with the
very latest hector break it down for us
hey there well nab said they had been
working for more than a year to bring
the show back but because of the public
health concerns they said they postponed
it to next year every year the national
association of broadcasters brings
insiders from the media and
entertainment industries to las vegas it
was supposed to happen october 10th
after getting canceled by the pandemic
in 2020 in a written statement nab said
in part quote unfortunately the pandemic
and surge of the delta variant has
presented unexpected and insurmountable
challenges for our global community we
also reached out to the las vegas
convention and visitors authority
president and ceo steve hill said quote
we deeply value our three-decade-long
partnership with nab and will greatly
miss seeing their exhibitors and
attendees this fall we eagerly await the
show's return in april
now as far as what impact this will have
on other conventions that remains to be
seen nab is the largest show for media
entertainment and technology in the
world so the economic hit will be hard
reporting in our newsroom hector mejia 8
news now